police investigating the disappearance
of 23 year old student McKenzie looook
are examining evidence seized from a
Salt Lake City home boxes of ammunition
were among multiple items removed during
an hours-long search yesterday the
unnamed homeowner is considered a person
of interest Jonathan Vigliotti is
outside the house Jonathan what led
police there good morning to Anthony I
spoke with the police chief who tells us
he was led to this property by what he
called digital footprints he's
confirming to us that they brought in
several cadaver dogs to assist with that
search he would not say if they detected
any kind of human scent though did say
they retrieve several or items from this
property that are now being tested for
DNA after a 19-hour search of this salt
lake city home police say their
investigation into University of Utah
student McKenzie Luke's disappearance is
quote moving very fast we collected
quite a bit of evidence from the from
the residence that that has now been
taken to be processed police say they're
looking for this mattress in a box
spring that were given away by someone
at the home last week investigators have
it named or arrested the homeowner but
confirm he is a person of interest court
and property documents show he's a
divorced 31 year old with no criminal
record in Utah do you know if he had any
connection whatsoever any communication
with McKenzie I think they spent several
hours talking to him as far as
communication we wouldn't divulge that
right now it's been 11 days since looook
landed at the Salt Lake City Airport she
took a ride sure from there to a park
about 11 miles away around 3:00 in the
morning police say she then got into
another car and hasn't been heard from
since her friends and family continue to
plead for her safe return it's been
extremely hard I had my moments where I
break down you've spoken with the family
how are they holding up as they navigate
all this uncertainty I'm sure this is a
very difficult time for them I've I've
only spoke to her father Greg in here
the pain the concern in the
breaking his voice I know the only thing
he wants right now is to see his
daughter again a lot of uncertainty and
waiting police say they have received
about 200 tips the search warrant
carried out here among several that had
been executed throughout the area and
Gail among those items that were
retrieved from here a car that was towed
away and is now being tested for DNA
I'm with Mackenzie's dad we all just
want to see her again
thank you very much Jonathan